[Musik]
noch hat Deutschlands bei der WM nicht
gespielt aber schon jetzt für ordentlich
Gesprächsstoff gesorgt Kapitän Manuel
Neuer wird keine one love-binde tragen
morgen zum Auftakt kein Zeichen für
Toleranz auf dem Rasen jetzt heißt
Manuel Neuer nur noch Manuel mutlos doch
es gibt noch viele andere spannende
Themen heute und spannende Gäste hier
bei 8:15 Uhr ich freue mich auf die
beste Rockstimme Deutschlands Sängerin
der Julia Neigel Schatten an der Wand
heißt einer ihrer größten Hits Millionen
Platten hat sie verkauft und sie will
weiter Geld in den Taschen haben denn
nur Bares ist wahres sie fürchtet die
schleichende Abschaffung des Bargelds
auch ein Verlust befürchtet der
Publizist Hendrik m broder und zwar den
Verlust unserer Kultur Kreuze werden
verbannt Weihnachtsmärkte heißen
wintermärkte verraten wir unsere
Geschichte und ich freue mich auf Soldat
Max Dominik Windisch er ist bereit mit
seinem eigenen Leben Deutschlands freier
zu verteidigen kämpft aktuell aber um
seine eigene Freiheit und spricht hier
heute zum ersten Mal über seinen
besonderen Fall denn er hat ein Befehl
verweigert den impfbefehl und das blieb
für ihn nicht ohne Konsequenzen und auch
mein Gast FDP-Politiker Volker Redder er
will raus aus der Steinzeit erhält
Deutschland in vielen Bereichen vor
allem in Sachen Digitalisierung für
rückständig und verschlafen
schön dass Sie da sind der große
Schlagzeile heute steht die Ampel vor
dem Aus der so geht's auf jeden Fall
nicht weiter das sagt FDP Vize Wolfgang
immer neue Forderungen von Rot Grün
immer mehr Schildkröten schlucken das
hat er heute bei uns im Studio gesagt
schauen wir rein
und was mich besonders nervt meine
Partei übrigens auch jeden Tag haben wir
Diskussion über Steuererhöhungen und
Abgaben besondere Art Frau esken kann
sich ja gar nicht mehr einholen vor
lauter Freude und vor allen Dingen
müssen wir dokumentieren auf den Vertrag
den wir geschlossen haben kann man sich
verlassen wer das in Frage stellt SPD
oder grüne der stellt diese Koalition in
frage ich muss nicht mein
parteivorsitzen erklären was Sache ist
das weiß er selbst ich muss meine
Koalitionspartner erklären dass diese
Form des Umgang mit einer ein Ende haben
muss oder wir haben ein fundamentales
Problem bei der Fortsetzung
fundamentale Probleme bei der
Fortsetzung Kubicki ist koalitions knall
könnte man sagen Herr Bruder sie haben
zugehört ist das jetzt der Anfang vom
Ende der Koalition nein das glaube ich
nicht die wollen durchhalten das sind
Droge werden das ist Action in den
Kulissen wobei ich meine er könnte schon
sagen lieber nicht regieren erschreckt
regieren aber so weit geht das genau das
Gegenteil gesagt lieber schlechtere
gerne als gut reagieren hauptsache man
ist dabei es ist ja kein Zufall
wahrscheinlich das olympische Motto
hauptsache man macht mit nicht und die
Ergebnisse naja das ist heute ist es
Sensation morgen ist ein Schall und
Rauch ja sehen Sie das auch so Herrer es
gibt so viele Themen Atom Bürgergeld die
Steuern man trennen sie sich wir treffen
uns nicht nein wir machen ja einen guten
Job das ist wir sind das bürgerliche
Korrektiv in einer überwiegenden
Regierung es muss man alle mal immer
bedenken dass wir eben nicht links sind
und natürlich gibt es Kompromisse die
gemacht werden müssen ich finde
Deutschland kann froh sein dass wir
dabei sind was ist denn die Alternative
ist da gibt es keine so richtige
Alternative momentan also müssen wir das
durchziehen und ich verstehe Kubik hier
auch in dem Sinne genauso dass wir uns
alle am Riemen reißen müssen das ist
seine Aufforderung und das stimmt auch
tatsächlich ja es gibt keine Alternative
wäre noch möglich
finden Sie das gut also nachdem wir
nachdem wir ja aber nachdem wir aber
nachdem wir die Großen Koalition ja
wirklich erlebt haben lange ich fand
nicht dass das Deutschland nach vorne
gebracht hat aber das ist ja auch ein
Thema wo wir gleich reden werden genau
im Einzelnen drauf dennoch muss man
sagen es gibt so viele Themen bei denen
sie nicht zusammenpassen mit vor allem
den Grünen wenn Sie das Hören Frau
Neigel das ist doch eigentlich hat man
halt so viele Themen ich habe das gerade
einmal aufgezählt dann passt einfach
nicht zusammen in der Beziehung als Paar
da würde man beispielsweise sagen also
wir mussten
wie so eine toxische Beziehung
gut jetzt kann man das nicht vergleichen
mit einer Bundesregierung aber es ist
schon so dass sich da zwei Parteien
gegenüberstehen insbesondere die Grünen
und die FDP die sehr sehr konträr denken
also die FDP sagt sie wäre eine
freiheitlich denken wir Partei die
Grünen zeigen sich im Moment aus meiner
Sicht eher ideologisch und es sind schon
Kontroverse Sichtweisen und Denkweisen
wie man ein Land regiert bei dem ich
denke das kann eigentlich nicht gehen
was glauben Sie warum bleiben die denn
zusammen es ist wie so ein Kleber an der
Macht kleben naja glauben heißt nicht
wissen aber ich vermute mal dass es
natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit ist für
die FDP an der Regierung zu sein und an
der Macht aber es ist manchmal auch ganz
klug zurückzutreten von zum Beispiel
einer Regierung und man sagt geht nicht
man ist zu weit auseinander und man geht
wieder zurück in die Opposition es kann
durchaus auch sehr glaubwürdig sein aber
wir haben uns ja ganz gut durchgesetzt
ne also in vielen Bereichen
mal wir haben ja noch wir haben jetzt ja
diese sehr merkwürdige Berlinwahl die
ist noch kommt dann haben wir die Bremen
Wahl die kommen dann gucken wir mal was
ich das bis dahin entwickelt hat ich
glaube dass die Grünen von den Umfrage
werden ja auch zurückgefallen sind jetzt
so gut so die CDU hat gewonnen die Union
hat gewonnen das stimmt bei den
Umfragewerten ähm aber mal ganz ehrlich
noch mal wir haben keine Alternativen
und es wird auch keine Neuwahlen es wird
keine Neuwahlen geben in der jetzigen
Situation da wird Steinmeier nie
Zustimmung
es gibt immer immer eine
Alternativen Fall der FDP da der nein
wir haben uns glaube ich ganz gut
arrangiert damit dass wir uns wie kleine
U-Boote an vielen Stellen durchsetzen
können das funktioniert
ja hat er auch recht man fühlt sich
manchmal wie beim Kröten Essen das
stimmt auch aber das geht den anderen
genauso das ist ja nicht nur die Sache
nicht besser
nee ich finde auch das mit der mit der
Ehe zu vergleichen ist schon sehr
schwierig aus dem gibt's
schwierig also ich finde es gut dass wir
uns streiten weil wir tatsächlich
wirklich aus völlig verschiedenen Ecken
kommen und sie haben völlig recht mit
der SPD kann man in bestimmten Bereichen
also gerade im Wirtschaftsbereich sehr
gut zusammen aber arbeiten bei den
Grünen jetzt eher dann um Bürgerrechte
da haben wir gewisse nehmen zueinander
aber ansonsten klar und nicht nur wir
streiten uns mit alle streiten sich
untereinander aber das ist doch toll
also der Diskurse der Wein steht für am
meisten zu einer besseren Lösung als
wenn wir uns alle einig werden immer
komisches bei der großen Koalition nicht
geklappt hat nee
Qualität
es gibt schon eine gewisse Kontinuität
in der deutschen vielleicht aber auch
einfach an dem schlechten
Spitzenkandidaten der Union
so stark auf dem Tisch haut wie groß ist
denn das in der FDP oder ist es jetzt
einfach seine Einzelmeinung
ja das ist schon groß aber es ist nicht
die Mehrheit
aber ein großes Lager und wie gehen Sie
damit um das ist ja normal in der Partei
das ist verschiedene Strömungen gibt und
man dann die ausdiskutiert und das hat
das sehr gut funktioniert
sie hören Politiker darüber sprechen ja
Streit ist normal ist das für sie etwas
dass sie mit Befremden aufnehmen oder
können Sie das Nachvollziehen ich kann
das durchaus nachvollziehen dass man
sich da nicht ganz einig ist aber dazu
werde ich mich jetzt nicht so ganz
weiter äußern ich halte mich da eher
zurück was das angeht ist nicht mein
Fachgebiet dennoch wir haben ja ganz
viele Probleme jetzt die Menschen haben
Angst vor der Arbeitslosigkeit die
Energiepreise die schießen in die Höhe
und jetzt haben wir die Koalition die so
viele Punkte hat in denen man sich nicht
einig ist welches Bild schafft man da
oder das finden Sie im Prinzip ist es
schon richtig dass man sich streitet wie
sagt man das bin ich ganz bei Ihnen haha
[Gelächter]
aber wissen Sie wenn Sie noch mal ich
muss darauf zurückkommen wir sagen es
gibt keine Alternative das ist Merkels
Philosophie das Scheitern natürlich gibt
es alternativ skandinavische Modelle wo
ist Minderheiten Regierungen gibt die
sich jeweils die Mehrheiten
zusammensuchen müssen es gibt
holländische Modelle es gibt ganz viele
andere Wege es zu machen nur wenn man
sozusagen an der Macht klebt um an der
Macht zu kleben ich glaube das schädigt
auf die Dauer die Fantasie sehe ich
genauso sagen Sie ruhig was
ich sage es gab noch nie
Minderheitsregierung in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland das hat
seinen Grund das ist hier ein bisschen
anders als in Dänemark wissen sie das
ist wie meine Lehre ich meine er hat
eine vage Erinnerung ja ich weiß wir
haben das immer so gemacht ja es richtig
was Neuem zu versuchen
also
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in Katar das
ist echt mal was ich überlegen Sie mal
was wir alles schon gutes gemacht haben
sie haben gesagt die Energiepreise
steigen jetzt und dann ist das stimmt
in der Regierung bleiben
ja auch weitermachen und wir wollen auch
zu ihrem Thema kommen dass ihr nämlich
ganz besonders wichtig ist
Digitalisierung das ist ein Thema das
wollen sie weiter vorantreiben ihre
Minute Ihre Kamera
unterbrechen
also bei Digitalisierung das ist ja ein
Thema was in allen Bereichen eine Rolle
spielt haben wir den letzten 12 15
Jahren tatsächlich verschlafen oder geh
schlafen und dann geht es natürlich
einmal um das föderalismusproblem das
ist eine Bundesrepublik die aus 16
Bundesländern besteht über 10.000
Kommunen und alle für nutzen
verschiedene IT-Systeme die man
irgendwie zusammenführen muss und da
erwarten wir eigentlich jetzt auch an
der Regierung dass sich da die Länder so
ein bisschen mehr committen zu dem was
wir eigentlich Vorhaben und das passiert
halt nicht die Länder und auch die
einzelnen Kommunen die ja man kann ja
sagen Selbstverantwortung haben
stimmen nicht in dem zu dass wir einen
Standard brauchen damit wir uns alle
Daten mal zusammenführen können und da
passiert auch beim beim Innenministerium
noch zu wenig um das nach vorne zu
bringen und das ist das zentrale Problem
wir werden dieses
digitalisierungsprobleme in Deutschland
nicht lösen können wenn nicht alle in
einem Strang ziehen und
das ist das eine das zweite Thema ist
diese Überregulierung die wir haben in
den ganzen Bereichen der
Verwaltung wo wir ja immer nicht 100%
liefern sondern 120%, das will er mich
nicht Ablage System was wir hier
perfektioniert haben ja Papier Pap
Papier sich davon zu lösen und sich
einmal von mal der Digitalisierung zu
stellen auch für die Mitarbeiter und
Mitarbeiterinnen das macht den Leuten
Angst und das führt dann dazu dass gar
nichts passiert oder an den falschen
Stellen was passiert und dann rede ich
natürlich noch von dem Datenschutz ich
bin als Liberaler Jahren absoluter
Datenschutz Fan aber man kann den
Datenschutz auch als
durchführungshilfe begreifen und nicht
als verhinderungsorganisation und das
sehen wir in Island die haben das
entsprechend geändert die haben den
Datenschutzbehörde die hilft den
Unternehmen die ganzen Sachen so zu
machen dass die datenschutzkonform sind
und hier ist es so dass sie machen
irgendwas und dann kommt ihr Datenschutz
und sagt nee geht nicht weit also
Umdenken an der Stelle dass er mal
zwingend notwendig damit man diese
Transformation hinkriegt weil wir müssen
sie hinkriegen das hat ganz viel mit mit
ja Zukunft zu tun aber auch damit dass
wir den Klimawandel beherrschen können
und und und und damit tatsächlich
zusammen aber sagen darf ich Ihnen gerne
erklären ein bisschen wie die Opposition
sie sind
eine weitere Kröte gegenüber die wir
eben gerade Sprachen würde Wolfgang
Kubicki sagen dann haben wir sie wieder
eine Kröte Digitalisierung
die Standards
darf ich zwei Beispiele so geht's nicht
weiter dann haben wir den Knall gehört
und dann gibt es nur einen Doppelpunkt
ganz ganz konkret zwei Beispiele nennen
es umweltfreundlich ist auch ein schönes
Beispiel die Banken in Deutschland
müssen regelmäßig berichten was sie für
Umsätze machen an die BaFin das wird
auch Papier gemacht dass die BaFin Tipp
das ab schick das an die EZB damit die
dann die Zinsen berechnen kann digital
so warum wird das schriftlich gemacht
weil es dazu entsprechendes Gesetz gab
das haben wir im Februar geändert seit 1
April wird das digital gemacht wissen
Sie wie viel also das sind 200.000 Blatt
Papier pro Bank wissen Sie wie Bäume
sind die man dadurch spart das ist
einfach eine Sache wo Digitalisierung
tatsächlich sofort zeigt das hilft was
sie sparen noch mehr Bäume werden den
Leuten das Benutzen von Toilettenpapier
finden
also gerade die Nutzung von Computern
die heizen ja auch auf
extrem hohen Anteil an am Klimawandel
haben besser gesagt an der an der
Erwärmung das ist so also und das wird
die ganze Zeit heruntergespielt und man
redet immer davon die Digitalisierung
ist irgendwie der Heilige Gral ich
überhaupt nicht
Leben wünschen Sie sich mehr
Digitalisierung im Leben überhaupt nicht
wo sind die Gefahren ich habe natürlich
mein Handy und ich habe natürlich auch
ein Portal wie Facebook wo ich auch was
schreibe und so weiter und so fort aber
ehrlich gesagt das bräuchte ich gar
nicht ich habe wunderbar davor gut ohne
gelebt ich brauche es persönlich für
mich nicht Steuererklärung Freude das
habe ich vorher immer mit Papier gemacht
und ich habe Freude daran mit Menschen
zu kommunizieren und ich würde ganz
ehrlich gesagt immer ganz viel lieber
auf der Bühne tun oder im persönlichen
Gespräch ich bin ein Mensch der mag
analog und ich habe es kommen sehen vor
vier Wochen oder vor zwei Monaten war
das als dann plötzlich irgendein Hacker
ein System geknackt hat an der
Tankstelle wo dann plötzlich die
Kreditkarten nicht mehr ging dann saß
ich da und dachte tja jetzt kommt's zum
ersten mal genau nehme ich das dass die
Leute dann mit Kreditkarte nicht mehr
sagen konnten krankenhäuser werden
geknackt das Thema darüber sprechen
gerade in der Musik spielt die
Digitalisierung eine große Rolle als
Segen aber gerade in der Musik drauf
ansprechen also anderes Politik in
Deutschland war ein Albtraum bezüglich
kulturerhaltung im Zusammenhang mit dem
Urheberrecht in digitalen Binnenmarkt
die sind hinterher die sind so etwas von
von hinterher das kann man gar nicht
vorstellen wir haben jetzt gerade vor
drei Monaten vor vier Monaten eine Klage
am Bundesverfassungsgericht eingereicht
wegen dem Urheber Dienstanbieter gesetzt
weil die deutsche Bundesregierung der
Auffassung ist dass man dem Publikum im
digitalen Binnenraum 15 Sekunden
Tonaufnahmen schenken darf die dürfen
sie frei nutzen denn das bagatellrecht
die wir bezahlen und unsere
Plattenfirmen und unsere Partner das
sind 15 Sekunden 15 Sekunden ist ein
gesamter Refrain das ist also das Werk
und sie sind die einzige Regierung in
ganz Europa die das gemacht hat das
sollte eigentlich positiv fürs
Urheberrecht und für die Künstler sein
und die
eu-heberrechtslinie umsetzen und die
haben natürlich wieder den Sonderweg
gegangen und ich würde sagen die
einzigen die an der Digitalisierung im
Moment in Deutschland verdienen und zwar
wirklich ganz dicke das sind die
digitalen Firmen und die meisten sind in
Silicon
den Mittelstand die zerstören auch die
Kulturland wir haben die darunter also
die Künstler verdienen verdienen
praktisch nichts also Pharrell William
hat irgendwann mal das Beispiel genannt
happy ein riesen Welthit ich glaube 20
Millionen Mal gestreamt 2000 Dollar da
kannst du ja in in Hollywood nicht mal
einen Monat von Leben
ist das cool aber auch selbst für
deutsche Künstler wird es wirklich
problematisch
bekommen bei der großen Labels also auch
keine Vorstellung ich bin in dem
Business ich war geh mal Aufsichtsrätin
ich bin wirklich ein und ausgegangen in
Brühl in Brüssel im
Wirtschaftsministerium in der Regierung
ich habe auf taube Ohren reden müssen
weil man sich gar nicht wir können das
nicht zurück drehen also das haben wir
zurück wie kann man das zurückrufen die
Digitalisierung zurückdrehen das ist
eine Technik wie alle anderen Techniken
auch es geht darum den sozial die
soziale Marktwirtschaft in die David in
die Digitalisierung hineinzubringen und
natürlich aus Urheberrecht dort zu
stärken weil es gibt praktisch kein
Urheberrechtsschutz in der
Digitalisierung
dasselbe gilt auch zum Beispiel für die
dsgvo-vorschriften es ist unglaublich
problematisch sei es auf Youtube
Facebook oder sonstwo also alle reden
davon wie toll Digitalisierung ist aber
gucken Sie bitte in die forbsliste wer
wirklich daran Geld verdient das ist die
USA digitalindustrie und nicht ahnt die
Digitalisierung
Fan Menschen machen sich überflüssig
genau
völlig neue Jobs entstanden
vor was das ist ein SEO Optimizer gibt
es ein typischer Job heutzutage
der macht Ihre Webseite so dass sie auch
bei Google gefunden wird
eine riesen Gewinn gemacht und die
ganzen Einzelhandel aber wir hatten doch
riesen Verlust gehabt deswegen ausholen
das MP3 Format ist ja keine
amerikanische Verbindung sondern das ist
in Deutschland
darum geht es schon weil dann gab es die
ersten Portale die MP3s so das was sie
heute bei Spotify auch bekommen die MP3
ist angeboten haben deutsche Firmen
haben das gemacht Bertelsmann war mit
dabei richtig und dann haben sie
aufgegeben und haben sich weitergeführt
brauchen gar nicht erst auf die weil sie
einfach aber wir haben doch wir haben
doch gerade noch Musikindustrie geredet
wir haben hier ganz viele Chance wir
haben hier ganz viele Chancen verpennt
ich fürchte da kommen wir gleich so ein
bisschen weil das geht ja ins Detail
nach der Sendung der Bruder fragt mich
gerade zurecht worum geht es her oder an
Sie die Frage schafft die
Digitalisierung die Menschheit ab wollen
wir das weiter denken nein also es gibt
zwei glaube ich es gibt es gibt halt ein
Fortschritt und beim Fortschritt immer
diese Widerstand gegen den Fortschritt
auf das war bei der ersten Eisenbahn
schon so dass er bei der Einführung des
Fernsehens ich kann mich an meine Eltern
lernen mit 10 Jahren Verspätung einen
Farbfernsehen Gerät sich gekauft haben
wer braucht schon Farbe ja nein das ist
ganz natürlich das ist ganz natürlich
genauso ja aber andererseits ist die
Digitalisierung ein gewaltiger
Fortschritt sie sparen derzeit Zeit sie
haben Zugang zu Informationen die sie
früher nicht hatten sie müssen nicht
mehr Schlange stehen in Folge qualmten
Stadtbibliotheken um sich darüber die
Fernleihe was zu leihen sie finden Sie
Netz dass es ein gewaltiger Fortschritt
und es ist so wie mit allem wissen sie
können sich ein Messer kaufen damit
können sie Brot schneiden oder ihrer
Eltern umbringen das ist dann ihre Wahl
meine bleiben sie Unrecht dann müssen
Sie die Gesetze so gestalten dass die
Menschen an der Digitalisierung auch
verdient ja die Menschen verändern
Digitalisierung und ich weiß nicht was
sie gegen die was Sie gegen die
amerikanischen Firmen haben das Problem
ist amerikanischen Firmen dass die
Deutschen Entwicklung verschlafen haben
können das ist Pläne gab eine deutsche
Ratingagentur zu schaffen und sich aus
der Macht der amerikanischen zu lösen
dann gab es ein europäisches
Satellitenprojekt Galileo
sehr erfolgreich tatsächlich ja ja es
funktioniert es ist deutlich genauer als
GPS aber es wird nicht angewandt doch es
wird gemixt inzwischen also man hat man
hat beides weil im Kriegssituation ist
genau also in Kriegssituation ist das
GPS Signal sehr ungenau für Navigation
damit Galileo benötigt damit Ihr Auto
Galileo funktioniert aber jetzt können
wir wieder zurück
was haptischen nämlich zum Geld und das
gehört zu unserem großen Thema
Digitalisierung dazu verneige das ist
ihr großes Thema denn sie wünschen sich
das weiterhin Bargeld in unseren Taschen
ist das nicht alles digitalisiert wird
ist richtig jetzt Pläne die
Innenministerin hat das gesagt eine
Obergrenze von 10000 € bei ihm geht ein
bisschen die Alarmglocken los sie
fürchten langfristig könnte es so kommen
dass wir alle nur noch ohne Bargeld
bezahlen müssen das ist zumindest der
langfristig geplant das habe ich
zumindest in den Reden gehört bei dem G7
Gipfel und dann gab es auch eine
hochrangige Konferenz am 7 November in
Brüssel in der es auch erwähnt wurde
dass man dahin steuern möchte ich möchte
eine kleine Geschichte erzählen ich war
am Flughafen in Frankfurt und wollte
ganz normal meinen Koffer einchecken und
er hatte da war zu schwer also da musste
noch etwas bezahlt werden ich wollte bar
bezahlen
und die Lufthansa wollte es nicht
annehmen und dann sagte man mir frech
ins Gesicht das ist ein bargeldloser
Flughafen
wie gesagt das geht gar nicht weil es
ein gesetzliches Zahlungsmittel ich bin
nebenbei dann noch zur Bäckerei wollte
eine apfelecke gegessen also für 1,50 €
oder so und die sagten das ist ein
bargeldloser Flughafen daraufhin habe
ich mich beschwert
beim Aufsichtsrat des Flughafens das ist
nämlich dafür das ist der Minister das
für Finanzen in Hessen der mir sagt es
sind gesetzliches also dieses
gesetzliche Mittel ist Banknoten und
Münzen und die müssen die tatsächlich
nehmen also das gibt diese Tests das hat
ja mal Jean-Claude Juncker auch gesagt
wir probieren es aus dann guck mal wie
weit wir kommen und dann probiert man es
halt in so einem hektischen flughaften
und wenn man dadurch kommt dann macht
man das
bei der Rundfunkgebühren
es wird nicht genommen das ist
eigentlich gerade genau tatsache ist
wenn ich nach China schaue und schaue
mir diese social
völliga
genau also es gab mal eu-parlamentar
Sicherheits Christian teres der hat
gesagt in einer Diktatur weiß der Staat
alles über den Bürger in einer
Demokratie weiß der Bürger alles über
den Staat und ich möchte eher die
Demokratie das heißt ich möchte kein
gläserner Mensch sein und ich möchte
auch bar zahlen können und nach Artikel
128 des AEUV Vertrags das ist nämlich
der Unionsvertrag gibt es nur ein
geltendes gesetzliches Zahlungsmittel
und es sind Banknoten und Münzen dann
gibt es noch das Kreditgeld also dass
man aus nichts schöpft und dann gibt's
noch das kreditbankengeld dass man
intern verwendet um die Seiden
auszugleichen digitale Euro stehen da
nicht drin das bedeutet man verstößt
sogar gegen Unionsrecht wenn man jetzt
den digitalen Euro einführt ohne alle
Staaten einstimmig abschließen zu lassen
oder abstimmen zu lassen ob sie den
Vertrag ändern würden weil die können
das gar nicht einführen ohne den Vertrag
zu ändern diesen Paragraph oder diesen
Artikel 128 sie haben schon ganz andere
Sachen
500 und 1000 Euro weil ich gut da ist
man für alle Eventualitäten also ich
habe auch daheim immer Bargeld weil es
einfach für mich Situationen gibt wo ich
es brauche und ich bin auch jemand der
immer wieder dran denkt
keine Ahnung Blackout wird ja jetzt auch
angekündigt kann in Städten passieren
oder wir haben zum Beispiel verbrennen
da kommt ja niemanden mehr an den
Bankautomat du kannst nirgends mehr Geld
abheben und ich lasse mich nicht darauf
ein dass ich meine Daten meine
persönlichen Daten sogar einer Bäckerei
am Flughafen in Frankfurt abgeben das
funktioniert nicht und ich rufe wirklich
alle Bürger auf sich dagegen auch zu
werden weil dieser Weg die Menschen
daran zu gewöhnen ihn in die Freiheiten
abzugewöhnen ist ein falscher Weg der
geht in in eine Form der Überwachung des
Überwachungsstaates das ist schon
passiert ich weiß ich versuche deine
Geld Überweisung zu machen und die
Postbeamten bestand darauf dass ich den
Zweck angebe
Finanzierung eines Bordells
hat das gemacht okay
völlig in Ordnung ja ich hätte auch
schreiben können Spende für den
raschenuntergang der Europäischen Union
wer auch hier gewesen
ja und wenn sie es mit einer
eingespülten Bürokratie zu tun haben der
allerdings ihre beste Zeit vor 45
bereits hinter sich hat dann haben sie
ständig solche Absurditäten und sie sind
schon ein gläserne Menschen ich auch
aber noch weiter möchte ich nicht sehen
lassen und ich gehe zum Beispiel nur
wenn ich einkaufen gehe immer bar ich
zahl immer bar sie haben keine
Kreditkarten natürlich habe ich aber ich
zahl trotzdem mal das ist für mich der
eine das ist eine reine Notsituation zum
Beispiel auch im Ausland aber ich halte
mich da ich bin der konservativ Bares es
war es ich zahle immer bar dann weiß ich
auch was ich auf der Hand habe ich habe
auch so angefangen zu arbeiten ich habe
mein Geld für meine Arbeit immer bar auf
die Hand gekriegt und deswegen weiß ich
auch mit Geld umzugehen für mich ist das
wichtig
sie verlieren die Kontrolle Karte zahlen
genau
28 zahle ist im gartengeld die Gefahr
die wir in China sehen dass die Leute
plötzlich ihre Konten gesperrt kriegen
und die die müssen praktisch an Handy
besitzen damit sie überhaupt an der
Gesellschaft teilnehmen ich meine wer
erzählt mir denn dass ich ein Handy
haben muss damit ich durch eine innen
Restaurant gehen kann
die Bankautomaten nicht funktionieren
sie stellen morgen treffen ja ja
Tankstelle
gerüstet aber jetzt mal Spaß beiseite
warum redet man in der Bundesregierung
darüber diese 10.000 Euro Obergrenze
schaffen
das ist der einzige Grund also selbst
sie sehen darin keinen anderen
sinnvollen Grund und das neue
Geldwäschegesetz das EU weitere Gesetze
und sind Vorschläge jetzt da die 10.000
ist ja noch eine schöne Summe nicht da
andere reden von 2000 € nicht Franzosen
waren noch 5000 von 5000 runter die
Italiener haben jetzt gerade von 2010
000 erhöht oder auf 12.000 sogar weiß
ich nicht genau aber die sind jetzt
wieder hochgegangen witzigerweise
eingeführt nein haben sie nicht
und Politik selber
aber sie wissen doch dass wir lieber
rein jetzt nicht für gegen das Bargeld
sind sondern wir sind nee
haben ein bisschen Kröten sammeln
gemacht
das zu machen dann müssen wir es als
Landes müssen wir es im Land umsetzen
das ist so deswegen werden genau weil
der Artikel 128 ist eine Startseite
das gleiche galt für die neu bei no bei
out Klausel das gleiche galt für die
übernahmekollektiver Schulden es gibt
kaum ein Gesetz gegen das die EU Länder
noch nicht verstoßen haben und das wird
gelassen
aber trotzdem nicht es läuft anders
wie positionieren Sie sich dazu wir
haben gerade über Digitalisierung
gesprochen wir wollen das Bargeld weiter
haben logischerweise keine Obergrenze
nein wir werden
15 werden
100 € wahrscheinlich
die Innenministerin möchte auch 5000
runter so wie es verstanden habe Frau
Feser ja das richtig
das müssen wir jetzt mit genau wie immer
da müssen wir uns jetzt streiten aber da
könnte ich jetzt eine Strichliste machen
Moment also hat mir Bürgergeld und jetzt
haben wir auch noch bargeldobergrenzen
mit der Innenministerin ich ganz feiner
wird die krötenliste
das ist so ja und die Frau immer wieder
also das ist schon das ist schon okay
das Geldwäschegesetz können wir nichts
machen tatsächlich
was machen
gesetzliche gesetzliche Regelungen
durchsetzen die Geldwäsche erstmal
unmöglich machen
genau
am Ende ihrer Karriere war bevor sie
wieder von der EU zum Leben erweckt
wurde ich weiß gehört nicht dazu
aber trotzdem wissen sie der 500 €
Schein wurde abgeschafft es wird immer
alles mit Geld gegründet
nein er wird nicht mal angenommen
wird nicht angenommen doch annehmen muss
man ihr das sie müssen nicht nur Leute
die ihn nicht annehmen
weil sie sagen die sind verpflichtet
Geld also Bargeld anzunehmen dann das
stimmt nicht doch nein das kann der
Dienstanbieter selber entscheiden
ist natürlich auch macht natürlich auch
eine Menge Arbeit für den Einzelhandel
ja ja
und wenn sie und will und wenn sie sagen
dass immer weniger Leute Bargeld nehmen
das stimmt das ja nicht die nehmen das
also trotz der Arbeit die die mit dem
Bargeld haben trotzdem sicher auf die
naja die machen sie immer noch
Schwarzarbeit verhindern
mit vielen anderen Sachen ja es gibt ein
Begriff in Deutschland der immer wieder
auftaucht an falscher Stelle
Generalverdacht genau
wenn ich auf die Straße gehe müsste ich
zum nächsten Bezirksbeauftragten und
nachweislich keine Waffe bei mir habe
was den Generalverdacht gibt ich könnte
eine Waffe bei mir haben und genau das
passt
wahrscheinlich wenn sie Gebrauchtwagen
kaufen das so wie das häufig so man
wirklich viel Geld Wechsel darf man
natürlich immer Bargeld dabei wenn man
irgendwo an einem Gebrauchtwagenhändler
rankommt Mann nein auf dem Weg zu Lidl
oder sie dürfen ja auch mal akzeptieren
dass das eine Situation und Bargeld auf
jeden Fall braucht und auch viel vage
wahrscheinlich auch 10.000 Euro kaufen
Gebrauchtwagen nein habe ich gesehen
meiner Sammlung aber
wenn jemand mit planen kann
kommentiert mit clankriminalität werde
ich jetzt gerade argumentiert es gibt ja
immer irgendeinen Grund ja gut aber es
wurde ganz konkretiert
das Problem das ist hausgemacht also die
clankreme Realität dafür muss ich nicht
auf mein Bargeld verzichten sorry das
ist nicht unser Thema dann müssen halt
die Politiker dafür sorgen dass diese
Parallelgesellschaften so nicht
existieren tut mir leid ja da kann der
Bund auch relativ wenig tun leider
natürlich
die Kompetenzen tun
aber nein
die Freiheit halten das steht steckt ja
sogar gut wirklich an die Frage also wir
lassen das Thema mit der kleinen ist
natürlich zuständig die jeweilige
Polizei vor Ort auch
Innenminister vor Ort und sie wissen
dass wir die Kleinkriminalität
reden wollen Konzentration haben in
Berlin wir haben Konzentrationen in
Bremen und wir haben Konzentration im
Ruhrgebiet das sind die
sozialdemokratischen Sinne das ist diese
eine Familie die sich da überall
ausgebreitet hat und da gibt es
Statistiken zu aber das tatsächlich
Ländersache das ist eben nicht
Bundessache das ist das Problem
machen wollen wir das Grundgesetz ändern
und den Föderalismus aufgeben man sollte
vielleicht Artikel 128a EUV einfach
akzeptieren und nicht an Anfang von
einem Bargeld zu reden okay wir machen
reden
wir machen eine ganz kurze Pause wir
sind gleich wieder hier bei 8:15 Uhr ich
freue mich über eine weiteres Thema dass
wir hier besprechen werden es geht um
die Impfpflicht in der Bundeswehr
bleiben Sie gerne bei uns bis gleich
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfernsehen wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glööckler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst
haben wir haben zu viel Staaten werden
die alle wegfallen und wir uns
gegenseitig in Berlin Mitte Cappuccinos
verkaufen das funktioniert nicht dann
ist alles essen als freiheitsliebender
Mensch würde ich sagen das muss jedem
erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und um Währungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch
was machbar ich finde aber diese gesamte
Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch ein
bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt über den wir reden soll
[Musik]
und da sind wir zurück bei 8:15 Uhr
schön dass ihr bei uns sind Max Windisch
ist unser Gast er soll dort bei der
Bundeswehr er ist also angetreten um
unsere Freiheit unser Land zu
verteidigen aber jetzt gerade führte
einen ganz besonderen Kampf um seine
eigene Freiheit denn er hat einen Befehl
verweigert den impfbefehl und das blieb
für Sie Herr minisch bei weitem nicht
ohne Konsequenzen das ist richtig von
vorne rein erstmal zu sagen ich bin kein
Verweigerer ich habe sämtliche nötigen
Impfungen die man braucht aber explizit
bei der Impfung habe ich ja eben
meine Bedenken sagen wir es mal so und
zwar man hat mir einen schriftlichen
Befehl gegeben mich impfen zu lassen
gegen mit biontech ich habe große
Bedenken die durch eigene Erlebnisse in
sogenannten amtshilfeaufträgen
entstanden sind ich war zum Beispiel
Impfzentren Seniorenheim Krankenhäusern
und Gesundheitsämtern tätig
in ein persönlichen Aufklärungsgespräch
mit einem probenarzt wurde meine Zweifel
noch größer denn es war mangelhaft und
unzureichend man konnte mir nichts
weiter zu werden Nebenwirkungen sagen
man sagte nicht dass das Produkt zu
diesem Zeitpunkt nur eine bedingte
Zulassung der EU hatte auch nicht dass
die klinischen Studien noch bis Ende
2022 laufen man wusste nicht welche
Inhaltsstoffe was in meinem Körper
bewirken zu diesem Zeitpunkt hatte ich
in meinem Umfeld schon negative
Beispiele beobachten können ein
ärztliche Untersuchung ergat zudem dass
ich schon eine natürlich Immunität mit
Antikörper entwickelt habe und dadurch
dass ich von Truppenarzt nicht
ordnungsgemäß informiert wurde wurde ich
auch nicht geimpft daraufhin bekam ich
eine disziplinarstraße von
53 Euro gegen diese Strafe habe ich in
einem Eifer fahren von Dienstgericht Süd
um eine Aussetzung geklagt das
Aktenzeichen ist S5 BLC 11/22 und für
jeden online einsehbar
ihr Fall ist sehr brisant sie passen
jetzt natürlich auf jedes Wort auf was
sie sagen und es braucht ganz ganz viel
Mut über diesen Fall hier auch zu
sprechen dafür erstmal danke dass Sie
hier sind dass sie diesen Mut aufbringen
ich weiß wir haben uns unterhalten auch
vor der Sendung das fällt ihnen nicht
leicht lassen Sie uns einmal zurückgehen
sie haben das gerade geschildert sie
wollten sich nicht impfen lassen ihm
gesagt das ist mir zu unsicher ich
beobachte auch in meiner Arbeit dass da
nicht genug geforscht wurde ich fühle
mich damit nicht wohl und dann mussten
sie erst meine Strafe zahlen und erstmal
zur Kasse gebeten genau also meine mein
Denken oder wie ich das ganze empfinde
resultiert daher dass Anfang 2020 der
erste Amtshilfe Auftrag eingeflogen kam
wo ich mich sofort freiwillig gemeldet
habe weil ich am Anfang schon bisschen
sag mal skeptisch gewesen bin bei der
ganzen Corona Sache Auftrag was ist das
genau also was macht man konnte Anträge
an die Bundeswehr stellen dass wir z.B
in Krankenhäusern aushelfen wo man eben
mit Arbeit nicht nach kann durch
Überlastung oder bei Gesundheitsämtern
wo eben die Listen geführt wurden zwecks
Kontaktpersonen dass man da eben
unterstützt hat und da habe ich mich
immer freiwillig gemeldet um mir eben
auch mal live ein Bild machen zu können
und es auch zu vergleichen ob das auch
was uns erzählt wird dem widerspiegel
was ich selber dort erlebe und das war
halt meistens niederfall gewesen was
haben sie da erlebt sie waren auch in
einem Pflegeheim sie waren
genau schon ganz alleine waren niemanden
niemand mehr zu ihnen dürfte genau also
das war der allererste amtshilfeantrag
überhaupt wir wurden da auch quasi ins
kalte Wasser geschmissen was das anging
wir sind da komplett für Mund
reingegangen in das ja in das Haus
es hieß es sind alle positiv auf die
Belegschaft und die Belegschaft ist
trotzdem nachmittags nach der Arbeit
nach Hause gefahren und kam dann wieder
auf Arbeit
wir waren die einzigen die mit
Schutzausstattung rumgerannt sind den
ganzen Tag das war sehr sehr anstrengend
für uns körperlich und das was die Krone
aufsetzt bei der ganzen Sache ist
einfach dass man uns dann beauftragt hat
mit den Bewohnern sage ich mal zu reden
weil die schon seit Wochen da drinne
sitzen und keinen Kontakt hatten zu
irgendwelchen Leuten außerhalb und dann
teilweise vor mir geweint haben weil sie
froh gewesen sind mit mir mal drei Sätze
sprechen zu können
es war ganz ganz schlimm
das Herz muss ich Ihnen ehrlich sagen
auch wenn Sie das jetzt hier schildern
was sie da erleben mussten dass die
Menschen dort in völliger Einsamkeit
gelassen wurden isoliert werden wurden
und sie waren dann der einzige Mensch
was haben Sie denn gesagt ja ich habe
mit ihnen über die täglichen Themen
geredet wie es dem geht und
ja ein paar die Älteren haben eben von
ihrer Geschichte erzählt was sie früher
so gemacht haben da konnte man ein
bisschen mit zuhören und das hat denen
dann wirklich gut getan sich dich auch
gemerkt und waren dann froh dass wir
überhaupt mal da gewesen sind auch wenn
es uns wieder mit dem Gesicht erkennen
konnten weil wir Musket getragen haben
eine Schutzbrille und ein
Ganzkörperanzug aber die waren froh dass
wir mit Ihnen reden konnten sie sind
kein im Verweigerer muss man sagen
findet gebracht der ist voll mit allen
Impfungen die man für die Bundeswehr
braucht und da bei der Impfung haben sie
aber gesagt das möchte ich nicht machen
und das hat riesige Konsequenzen für sie
gehabt wir haben jetzt einmal das Geld
erwähnt aber das ist ja vor Gericht
gegangen und alles mögliche und dieser
Prozess ist noch lange nicht
abgeschlossen was
ich da gerade auf sie herein ja man
versucht mich jetzt halt rauszukriegen
aus der Bundeswehr ich habe
Akteneinsicht gehabt von meinen Akten
und konnte halt raus lesen dass man mich
einfach sofort gerne entfernen möchte
was aber nicht funktioniert ich bin
schon zu lange dabei das gibt meine
Dienstzeit eben nicht her und
ja man will darauf hinaus dass ich
unernhaft entlassen werde was macht das
mit ihnen das macht mich psychisch
fertig weil ich keinen Ansprechpartner
habe es gibt ja keinen der mit mir
darüber reden kann und ich bin da eher
auf mich allein gestellt und werde
allein gelassen auch im Dienst es gibt
da niemanden die sind alle eher so ganz
vorsichtig bei dem Thema Weise alle
Angst haben dass irgendwas Falsches
gesagt wird und ja da habe ich bei mir
eben nur die Familie und meine verlobtet
mit der ich da ein bisschen reden kann
also da haben sie jetzt zumindest einen
Felsen in der Brandung gekommen
Kameradinnen oder Kameraden auf sie zu
wie ist man umgegangen bei der
Bundeswehr mit diesem ganzen im Thema
anfänglich war das viel viel schlimmer
als es jetzt ist man hat mich
entschieden jetzt ist beim Antreten
solche Sprüche abgelassen wie ach so
fühlt sich anliegenden querdinger zu
stehen und solche Sachen sind dann halt
gefahren wo ich dann auch nicht
beschwert habe dass das ja nicht sein
kann und jetzt erst wo sie sehen dass
ich da was dafür tue und das dieser
Beschluss existiert kommt es auf einmal
zu mir super dass du dich für uns
einsetzt finde ich klasse aber wir
stehen hinter dir ganz weit hinter dir
mach du mal und wenn du Erfolg hast
Träume für dich aber wir wollen uns dann
nicht mit einmischen weil wir Angst
haben
und was sagen sie dann sie sind
weiterhin alleine und ich bin weiterhin
so gesehen alleine es gibt einige wenige
es gibt in meinen Bataillon zumindest
die das gleiche Schicksal erheit hat die
stehen natürlich zusammen viel mehr sind
in diversen Gruppen auf Telegramm wo wir
uns dann untereinander alle
kennengelernt haben da gibt es sehr viel
Rückhalt und Zuspruch das finde ich sehr
sehr gut dass es das gibt aber ansonsten
bin ich eigentlich einen großen Ganzen
allein das kommt immer nur so Aussagen
wie du hast damals was unterschrieben
treu zu dienen also setzt dich hinten
macht dein Arm frei und reden also
verweigert das einfach nicht anfänglich
jedes Jahr auch noch ich schütze mich
und die anderen daraufhin hatte ich auch
schon drei Impftermine gehabt aber das
dieses Argument die wir dann irgendwann
mal aus und dann hieß es nur noch du
bist
impfen zu lassen und das macht das auch
da ging es ja nur noch um den Befehl
einfach soll die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht die läuft Ende des Jahres
aus die wackelt mehr als
muss man sagen es ist ja wahrscheinlich
dass sie nicht verlängert wird was ist
mit der Impfpflicht für die Soldatinnen
und Soldaten
so der Fall ist jetzt ja was ganz
Besonderes vor allen Dingen unter dem
Aspekt dass sie hier gerade eben erzählt
haben dass sie einen antikörpertita
haben einen hohen das heißt sie haben ja
eigentlich den Nachweis dass sie das gar
nicht mehr kriegen können ja also laut
den laborbefinden den zweien die ich
habe die habe ich ja aus eigener Tasche
bezahlt einfach um sage ich mal
drumherum zu kommen er steht drin
geschrieben dass man von einer Immunität
bei mir ausgehen kann nach überstanden
Infektionen oder Impfungen aber es gibt
leider keine Studien keine Studien
diesbezüglich deswegen kann man das
nicht anerkennen also man hat mir von
Seiten der Ärzteschaft aus immer so ein
vier Wochen Zeitraum gegeben in den vier
Wochen hätte ich entweder noch mal so
ein Test machen sollen aus eigener
Tasche und dann hätte man mich weiterhin
nicht impfen können aber unsere
Ärzteschaft die dafür diese Antikörper
Nachweise nicht mehr machen wurde
befohlen haha okay also erstmal ja das
Problem ist natürlich Soldaten ich kenne
das ja man unterschreibt im Endeffekt
ganz viel und man geht natürlich seine
Freiheit ab wenn man Soldat ist das ist
ja
Zeichen der demokratische Bürger in
Uniform man hat Befehl und Gehorsam und
wenn das so ist und das sozusagen in der
ZDV zentralen Dienstvorschrift drinsteht
und in den entsprechenden Regularien
dann hat man als Soldat zu gehorchen das
ist leider so und aber in diesem Fall
aber ganz ehrlich in diesem Fall
alternativlos
zum Beispiel zum Beispiel die
Menschenrechte die gehen von Konvention
definieren Ausnahmen so jetzt kann man
darüber diskutieren ob damit ihre
körperliche Ebene verletzt wird
das kann ich aber auch nicht beurteilen
ich beurteile aber auf jeden Fall dass
das schwachsinnig ist dass sie sich noch
mal impfen lassen müssen wenn sie so
einen hohen Titel haben
dass sie Impfpflicht auch bei der
Bundeswehr gibt es jetzt ihre Aufgabe
sie sitzen in der Regierung also
ich würde also von mal ganz vorsichtig
an Sie haben gerade ihren Impfausweis
gezeigt wenn ich in Mali im Einsatz bin
dann muss ich mich gegen
gelbfieberimpfen lassen gehen viele
gegen viele gegen viele andere Sachen
genau bei Corona unter den aktuellen
also insofern Corona unter den aktuellen
Situationen Virus den wir gerade haben
kann man glaube ich vor allen Dingen in
ihrem Alter gut drauf verzichten da
würde ich tatsächlich zu einer
freiwilligen Variante wechseln
Virus ist ja nicht relevant es geht ja
auch um
die Sicherheitsbedingungen die die bei
diesem Produkt bezüglich der
corona-schutzimpfung gefehlt haben das
ist ja bedingt zugelassen gewesen
es gibt keine ordentlichen normalerweise
15 Jahre brauchen wir normal und dann
ist es noch neuartig die klinischen
Studien laufen noch bis nächstes Jahr im
Dezember 13 23
was sagen sie sie Herr Windisch hat uns
das gerade so geschildert was er auch
ertragen muss also er leidet darunter
ihm wird Geld weggenommen er dieser
Prozess ist lange nicht vorbei und also
ich persönlich kann man sagen das ist
Mobbing ich sehe darin einen
unzumutbaren Befehl weil ich der
Auffassung bin man kann bei einer
bedingten Zulassung keine
Duldungspflicht oder wie auch immer es
beschönigt genannt wird durchführen mit
einem Produkt bei dem zudem ihnen
aufklärungsbögen ich habe das mir vorhin
angesehen drin steht es sterben ab und
an halt auch Menschen dran und zwar
Männer an Herzmuskelentzündung so er ist
offenkundig ganz klar Mann es gibt ich
sehe das nicht so wie sie das ist also
das sind Soldat in dem Moment wo er
Soldat wird sein Hirn und seinen
Verstand und alles abgeben sein Körper
und sich erschlagen und töten lassen
muss für alle für alle Belange nein es
gibt uns zumutbare Beziehung ja aber es
gibt
nein aber ich sehe es eben nicht so dass
du Soldat sozusagen gar keine Rechte
mehr hat natürlich hat er die auch als
Patient hatte und es gibt ein Urteil zum
Beispiel in Neuseeland hat man im März
diesen Jahres
die Polizei Polizei sollte geimpft
werden da gab es auch eine Impfpflicht
ist ja auch Staatsdiener und da wurde
vom Obersten Gericht entschieden dass
das völkerrechtswidrig ist und
menschenrechtswidrig und natürlich auch
verfassungswidrig dann haben wir
in
New York jetzt dieses Gerichtsurteil des
vom Obersten Gericht dass die
Feuerwehrleute wieder eingestellt werden
müssen und natürlichen Gesundheitsstatus
weil es eine Form der Diskriminierung
war das sagt die Premierministerin zum
Beispiel auch von der regional Berater
in Kanada ich halte denn Umgang Menschen
in einen medizinischen Versuch zu
nötigen ob Soldat Polizist oder Zivilist
für ein Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit ich halte es auch ich
halte ich halte es für auch eine Form
der psychischen Körperverletzung jede
Impfung ist dass meine Körperverletzung
deswegen müssen die Ärzte die Patienten
aufklären das heißt der Eingriff in die
körperliche Integrität findet statt
dagegen darf er sich werden er muss sich
sogar werden ein recht und es stimmt
nicht dass das nur eine Fiktion war das
Bürger in Uniform und der mündiger
Bürger das war lange Zeit ein Konzept
Missbrauchsfälle es gab eine
unglaubliche Aufregung darüber dass es
nicht immer so funktioniert
Bruder
die Politik entschuldigen vielleicht
sogar noch mehr muss sie helfen muss sie
ein Windisch helfen nein was er alles
jetzt zeigen
nein nein die Politik nein sie bitte
entschuldige bitte jedes Todesurteil ist
ein Sonderfall ja nein nein oder eine
Rechtsprechung in einer demokratischen
Stadt lebt davon dass sie jeden
Sonderfall einzeln behandelt gerade
berichtet was gelaufen ist er hat
berichtet dass er einen dass er ist auch
ein sehr hart berichtete
hat und jeder normale Stabsarzt würde
sagen du brauchst keine Impfung mehr das
ist aber nicht passieren
kann
auf ihre Frage zurückkommen natürlich
aber das ist kein Argument sorry hier
geht's um den Eingriff in seinen Körper
durch eine Infektion Autounfall haben
wir doch gerade schon geklärt ich habe
ja schon gesagt
es geht nicht alleine um die Antikörper
es geht darum dass wir hier in
medizinisches Experiment haben dieses
Produkt ist nur bedingt zugelassen und
damit hat er nach dem Völkerrecht nach
Artikel 7 Satz
ist hier ein Mensch das kommt hinzu
genau seine Freiheit kämpft der für
seinen Beruf kämpft und der darum kämpft
ich hoffe ich fasse es in richtige Wort
in ihrem Sinne aber Scheren Sie bitte
jederzeit ein natürlich so zu
akzeptieren und seine Entscheidungen so
angenommen zu bekommen man trägt mich ja
wie gesagt in eine Ecke und ich dachte
auch nach dem Beschluss den der Richter
bei mir gefällt hat wo dann alle auch
die Feuer gegen mich geschossen haben
auf einmal gesagt haben oh ein Glück ich
war die vierte wollte ich mir sowieso
nicht geben oder die dritte habe ich dir
am nächsten Tag leider den nächsten
Befehl erhalten genau denselben Wortlaut
nur das Datum geändert und das ist für
mich dann eigentlich nur schikaner wenn
ich sogar schon Nötigung dass man macht
ich war genauso es ist genauso wie keine
wie ein großer Teil der Corona Maßnahmen
es sind Leute festgenommen worden ja
meine Partner gesessen im Buch gelesen
haben es ein junger Leute
Leute
wissen sie können die Österreicher nicht
für alles
in Hamburg mit dem Gefühl mit dem
hubschrauberjahr
man hat normale Entschuldigung
hausfrauen von der Elbe weggescheucht
weil sie dort spazieren gegangen sind
oder was man produzieren im Extremfall
eine solche Art und schon sieht von
Sonderbehandlung und wir haben diesen
komischen Arzt Komiker gehabt dr
Montgomery angeblich Präsident eines
bundeste Pflicht Soldaten ich weiß es
nicht der hat von der Tyrannei der
ungeimpften gesprochen ja und das war es
war der es war sozusagen der kleinste
gemeinsame Nenner dieser ganzen Papagei
am Anfang ja wissen Sie überhaupt nicht
Alter ich möchte eigentlich sein sie
möchte
ein Wahnsinn Konflikt mit meiner Familie
und der erste Weltmeister
wurde geschrieben eben dass das ganze
eine umfangreichen
Sachverhaltsermittlung eben einhergeht
aber meines Erachtens nach kann diese
Sachverhaltsermittlung gar nicht
stattfinden weil der Inspekteur des
Sanitätsdienstes der Bundeswehr da
verweigert jegliche Aussage zu einem
Fragenkatalog diesbezüglich also warum
erstaunlich verstehe ich nicht und auch
im Juli gab es einen Prozess mit zwei
Offizieren der Luftwaffe in Leipzig beim
Bundesverwaltungsgericht und der
Beschluss sagt dort eindeutig es steht
drin geschrieben dass wenn neue
Erkenntnisse zu dieser Impfung
erscheinen oder eintreten dass man
gegebenenfalls die dehnungspflicht
anpassen sollte und ich würde mir
wünschen dass die Bundeswehr da mal
langsam dem nachkommt weil wir wissen ja
mittlerweile alle dass diese Impfung
wenn überhaupt vor einem schweren
Verlauf schützt die schützt er die
übertragen
lassen und
Soldaten ist jetzt paragra sitzen Alpha
Absatz 1 steht der geschrieben dass so
eine Impfung nur durchführungspflichtig
ist oder für mich da drüben ist wenn sie
nachweislich mich schützt und
Gegenübertragung
das tut sie weder noch und trotzdem wird
man zumindest drei Impfungen gedrängt
Herr Windisch vielen Dank für ihren Mut
das hätte hinsetzen ich weiß das war für
sie ganz besonders schwierig auch sie
haben ganz viel erlebt bei diesem Thema
und wir bleiben in Kontakt ich hoffe
sehr sie kommen auch wieder hierher wir
wollen wissen wie es bei ihnen
weitergeht und Herr Bruder sie verzeih
mir dass wir für Ihr Thema jetzt nur
noch sehr weniger Zeit haben aber
genau
darüber gesprochen es werden wir auch
noch aber ich möchte dann auch noch auf
ihr Thema zu sprechen kommen denn auch
das greift ein Zeitgeist auf es geht um
unsere Kultur und immerhin befürchten
sie dass wir uns von der mehr oder
weniger verabschieden es gibt einen
Kulturkampf der von dieser Regierung
vielleicht nicht angezettelt aber
konsequent weitergeführt wird es gibt in
Berlin diese großartige Stiftung
Preußischer Kultur besetzt die das Erbe
nicht nur Preußen sondern auch andere
Kulturgüter verwaltet das soll jetzt bei
der Umbau dieser Stiftung sollte Begriff
Preußen aus dem Titel genommen werden
weil Preußen wird bei uns immer noch
konnotiert mit Militär und Marschmusik
für mich ist was anderes das zum
Beispiel größere Formel für Freiherr von
Stein oder August von Hardenberg der am
großere Formen durchgesetzt die nach
heute bedeuten sind aber Preußen muss da
raus aus dem Titel der Kulturstiftung
aus Gründen die vermutlich uns nur
Claudia Roth erklären kann und ich
glaube auch sie käme in
argumentationsschwierigkeiten ein
anderes Beispiel wenn Sie mir noch paar
Sekunden können wir
haben noch mehr gut dann muss ich nicht
so hetzen
das hat ja vor kurzem das Treffen der
Außenminister der G7 gegeben in Münster
und vermutlich in dem Saal in dem auch
der festfälische Frieden verhandelt
wurde und vor dem Treffen wurde ein
Kreuz das an der Wand hinkrieg entfernt
entfernt verstehen sie meine man muss
nicht Christ sein schon gar nicht ein
praktizierender aber sie leben in einer
christlich geprägten Kultur und da wird
ein Kreuz abgegangen bei einem Treffen
der Außenminister ohne dass ich jemand
darüber beschwert hätte das keinen Fall
bekannt geworden weil Jude oder ein
Moslem oder eine Atheist sich darüber
beschwert hätte naja und dann gab es
wirklich das deutsche durcheinander Frau
bärburg die dann die Konferenzleiter der
dauerte die Maßnahme und sagte dieser
Maßnahme habe sei keine politische
sondern nur eine organisatorische
Entscheidung gewesen ja ja das hat sie
wirklich gesagt das heißt und ich hatte
ja dafür entschuldigt und der spreche
das ausländischen des Auswärtigen Amtes
sagte noch was witziger
es habe eine Veränderung des Mobiliars
gegeben und im Zusammenhang dieser
Veränderung des Mobiliars anderer Tisch
andere Beleuchtung andere Teppiche sagen
das Kreuz sind ja aber es geht noch
weiter nächstes
Ärgernis die Kuppel des Berliner Doms
trägt eine Inschrift die von wie ist
denn noch mal der Kaiser Friedrich
Wilhelm IV 1844
angeordnet wurde ein völlig harmloses
Zitat aus der Bibel ich weiß nicht was
neues oder altes Testament ist es geht
darum dass die Menschen sich in die
Macht Gottes begeben und Claudia Roth
ich tut mir leid dass ich Sie wieder
zitiere aber leider hat sie mein Leben
schon viel zu oft gekreuzt Claudia rot
sagt dieser Spruch dieser Spruch ist
kein unpolitisches Zeichen von
Religiosität oder eine politische
Botschaft die den von Gott abgeleitet
der Herrschaftsanspruch des
Preußenkönigs untermauern es wird von
allem erstmal eine Gefahr oder zumindest
jemanden auf die Füße tritt oder sowas
ich glaube das entspricht einfach nicht
im Weltbild ist wie auch in der letzten
Fall mit Münster ist auch in diesem Fall
glaube ich noch keine einzige Beschwerde
eingegangen von einem Mann des Gläubigen
und man muss sich vorstellen dass hier
dieses gottesnahmt und wieder beschworen
wird dieser Preußenkönig ist wann ist er
gestorben 1861 aber für das Rot lebt er
gleich
immer noch weiter und knechtet uns und
unsere Bekenntnisse mein Bruder ihnen
wird heute eine große Ehre zuteil sie
hatten nämlich damit das Schlusswort und
damit möchte ich sie hatte gerade das
angefangen
den nächsten Wochen noch mal einladen
ich hoffe Sie nehmen einfach die
Einladung an meiner Familie Fragen genau
bitte einmal die bitte an Herrn Broders
Familie er möchte bitte oder ich möchte
das auch sehr gerne wenn Sie erlauben
noch
mal hier an der Stelle weiter einmal
eine Notiz genau
ich möchte mich ganz herzlich hier bei
meinen Gästen bedanken es war eine
spannende Diskussion hier bei 8:15 Uhr
und wünsche allen noch einen schönen
Abend herzlichen Dank
[Musik]